>> Hi, YouTube.
My name is Shafik Gabr, I am an entrepreneur
from Egypt.
I have had the pleasure of being asked this
difficult question and I
will give it my best shot.
My feeling is if there's one thing that could
be asked for making the
world a better place in 2008 is to be able
to ask for political
leaders to stand up to the challenges that
they have and the conflicts
that are costing people lives around the world
not only in our part of
the region, in the Arab world, in the Middle
East, but in Asia, Latin
America, other parts of the world.
I think the world needs more people like President
Sadat who was able
to stand up to responsibility, take up the
challenge, and be able to
find sustainable, just, and peaceful solutions
that have the grace and
it sort of bottom line and unless people stand
up to that
responsibility, sadly enough given the state
of the world, I think we
will enter into a viscous circle which will
continue and maybe even
get worse.
If there's one thing that I hope 2008 will
bring is to provide vision
and courage to our political leaders to stand
up and take that sort of
responsibility, work together as a team, and
to be able to make this
world a better place.